coastal communities from South Florida
through the Carolinas are preparing for
the worst as Dorian approaches mandatory
evacuation orders will be in effect
later today in more than a dozen
counties across three states nine of
them in Florida alone seven other
counties there are under voluntary
evacuation orders
mark Strassmann is on the beach in st.
Augustine Florida about 40 miles
southeast of Jacksonville Mark's well
mark what's happening there good morning
good morning
what's happening here is this everyone
who lives on this beach and everyone who
lives in st. Augustine has to get out
later today
the county is imposing a mandatory
evacuation order that begins later this
morning as this hurricane moves closer
to shore everyone agrees that Dorian
looks daunting healthfirst cape
canaveral hospital was taking no chances
dozens of patients hurting and
vulnerable were moved inland and away
from Dorian's menace in st. Augustine
Joe Cole sent packed up what he can't
live without the contents of his safe
and his family of four do you typically
stay or do you typically that we we've
go depending on the storm sometimes we
stay but this one is like definitely get
out of here yeah and why is that
I think the catastrophic dimensions of
the five and the immensity of the storm
and how it's moving for reference I want
to show you why people here take durian
seriously this is the same spot three
years ago when Hurricane Matthew flooded
city streets for blocks like durian
Matthew was a monster category five
storm
coastal Florida now is battening down
and boarding up with widespread
evacuation orders in effect
Florida Governor Ron de Santos if you
are ordered to evacuate you know safety
comes first and you don't want to mess
with the storm that is going at 185
miles per hour and her forest and Greg
Goldstein told us labor day tourism
plummeting their juice bar business was
down at least 50% it's not what we
expected the streets here those empty
streets may have hurt the area
financially but they helped rob Hardwick
the st. Augustine Beach Police Chief has
fewer people to worry about
I just don't be complacent because one
shift in a few degrees and it's on top
of us
Airport closures are another sign that
durian scares this Coast
Palm Beach County International Airport
is already closed and airports in
Melbourne and in Fort Lauderdale will be
closing at noon today Anthony all right
mark thank you you can follow hurricane
durian around the clock and watch our
streaming service CBS n with our CBS
news app or by logging onto CBS news.com